Trong rằng người ngu nước ở khoảng trường gà đình sáng 2 tháng chính,
nồi bắt là những đoàn cụ chính bình từ khắp mọi miền đất nước,
họ măng trên mi bộ quân phục mào sang đã mặt mào thời gian,
lực đầy huy chương, bước đi trong niềm xuất lọc tự hào.
Nếu cụ chính bình chia sẻ, được tận mắt chúng kiến lễ dễu vình dễu hành trong này
tết độc lập là khoảng khắp đặc biệt thương liên,
gợi nhất kiếp về những năm tháng chính đấu San Ho, để vào việc lên độc lập không nay.
Thì các khối quân đội hủ súng tính có lễ dài,
những cụ bình dạ lạc lễ đứng nghiêm dơ tài chào theo điều lệnh,
anh mắt dương dương.
Có người xúc độc nói,
thình anh lấp lấp thế hệ chẻ trong hàng ngủ,
chính là sự tiếp lối của chuyển thống Anh Hùng,
là lời khẳng định đất nước luôn được bảo vệ vững chắc.
Không chỉ có những cái mắt tay,
khai ông Sizz chặt giữa đồng đội của khắp lại,
mà còn có cả những lụng quời San lẫn sọc nước mất.
Bối họ, lễ kiện nghiệm tả mùi năm quốc khảnh,
không chỉ là một sự kiện trọng đại của đất nước,
mà còn là dịp để nhất giữa thế hệ mai sau về giả chị của độc lập tự sau.
Dữa không kiểu hồng của ngày hội nóng sông,
những cụ trên bình chính là chính nhân sống,
gắn kết quả khứa sân lào với hiện tại Anh Hùng,
để từ đó gửi gắm nhìn pin,
khách bọng và một Việt Nam phát triển sau mạnh và bình vững.